et des caractéristiques faciales d'achondroplasie,
mon front et mon nez.
Mes bras ne se déplient pas complètement
mais je peux lécher mon coude.
Je ne vous le montrerai pas.
L'achondroplasie apparaît chez environ un bébé sur 20 000.
80% des gens petits sont nés de deux parents de taille moyenne.
Quiconque dans la pièce pourrait avoir un enfant atteint d'achondroplasie.
Mais j'ai hérité ma pathologie de mon père.
J'aimerais vous montrer une photo de ma famille.
Ma mère est de taille moyenne,
mon père est une petite personne
et je suis l'aînée de cinq enfants.
J'ai trois sœurs et un frère.
Ils font tous une taille moyenne.
J'ai eu la chance incroyable de naître dans une famille
qui a cultivé ma curiosité et ma ténacité,
cela m'a protégée de la méchanceté et de l'ignorance des inconnus
et m'a armée de la résilience, de la créativité et de la confiance en moi
nécessaires pour survivre et manipuler l'environnement physique et la société.
Si je devais identifier une raison à ma réussite,
c'est parce que j'étais et suis une enfant aimée,
une enfant aimée pleine d'insolence et de sarcasme,
mais une enfant aimée malgré tout.
En vous donnant un aperçu de qui je suis aujourd'hui,
je voulais vous offrir un point de vue nouveau.
Je voulais contester l'idée
selon laquelle le design n'est qu'un outil
pour créer fonctionnalité et beauté.
Le design affecte grandement la vie des gens,
la vie de tous.
Le design est une façon de nous sentir inclus dans le monde,
mais c'est aussi une façon de faire respecter la dignité
et les droits d'une personne.
Le design peut infliger de la vulnérabilité
à un groupe dont les besoins ne sont pas considérés.
Aujourd'hui, je veux que vos points de vue soient remis en cause.
Pour qui concevons-nous ?
Comment pouvons-nous amplifier leur voix
et leurs expériences ?
Quelle est la prochaine étape ?
Le design est un énorme privilège
mais c'est une responsabilité encore plus grande.
Je veux que vous ouvriez les yeux.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)